Hey Will, how do you pronounce C-H-O-W-D-E-R? The word? Oh yeah, not the letters. Chowda. How do you, what do you say? Chowder. C-H-O-W-D-E-R. Yeah.
嘿，威尔，你怎么发 C-H-O-W-D-E-R 的音？这个词？哦，对，不是拼字母。Chowda。你怎么，你怎么说？Chowder。C-H-O-W-D-E-R。对。
Chowda. I'm sorry. Are we reading the same, because I, okay, hang on. You're right, I'm totally right. Let me look it up. Let me, let me, C-H-O-W-D-E-R. D-E-R. Yeah.
Chowda。抱歉。我们读的是同一个，因为我，好吧，等一下。你是对的，我完全是对的。让我查一下。让，让，C-H-O-W-D-E-R。D-E-R。对。
It's like as in clam. Chowda. So chowder. Let's see. Chowder. Yeah, there's an R. That's great. Thank you, Jason.
就像蛤蜊的那个。Chowda。所以是 chowder。我看看。Chowder。对，有个 R。太好了。谢谢你，杰森。
That was Jason. Chowder. Yeah, no, we, Jason, we heard you. Chowder. So we're saying the same word, right? Yes. Chowda. So we're saying the same word, right?
那是杰森。Chowder。对，不，我们，杰森，我们听到了。Chowder。所以我们说的是同一个词，对吧？是的。Chowda。所以我们说的是同一个词，对吧？
Chowder. There's no smartlist. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Chowder。没有 smartlist。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Oh, there's Sunshine. Oh, hi Sunshine. Everyone's hatless today. Hey. You guys going to go play golf today? Yeah.
Smart。Smart。哦，阳光来了。哦，嗨，阳光。今天大家都没戴帽子。嘿。你们今天要去打高尔夫吗？对。
Yeah. Mini golf or big golf? No, no, no, adult golf. Oh. We're going to play adult golf. So, Will wore his golf shirt to the broadcast today. I took mine off because I didn't want to get any heat from you guys, so I'm in a little sweatshirt here.
对。迷你高尔夫还是大人高尔夫？不，不，不，大人高尔夫。哦。我们要去打大人高尔夫。所以，威尔今天广播时穿着他的高尔夫衬衫。我把我的脱了，因为我不想挨你们的批，所以我穿了件小卫衣。
You know why? Because I'm not worried about that kind of shit, dude, because I'm comfortable with who I am. Wait, do you see my polyester shirt today? Lots of stripes, accents on the collar. Yeah, I kind of could have. What kind of stripes are they? They're horizontal, they're fattening stripes.
你知道为什么吗？因为我不在乎那种狗屁，老兄，因为我对自己的身份感到自在。等等，你看到我今天的涤纶衬衫了吗？好多条纹，领子上有装饰。对，我差不多能。那是什么样的条纹？它们是横条纹，显胖的条纹。
Oh, dude. I mean, you're not doing yourself any favor, and you're not stopping the chatter with that. You think I should go to verticals? Well, I'm just saying, how do you feel about the chatter? Have you heard about the chatter? Yeah. There's been a ton of...
哦，老兄。我的意思是，你没有帮到自己，你也没法用那个堵住大家的闲话。你觉得我应该换成竖条纹的吗？好吧，我只是说，你对这些闲话有什么感觉？你听到过那些闲话吗？对。有超级多……
Yeah, is there some talk? Well, there's been a bit of chatter. I just need to stop eating, stop eating after six. I think I'd be okay. What did you do this weekend, Jason? Oh. So my neck, Jesus Christ. What?
对，有什么流言吗？好吧，确实有些闲话。我只是需要停止吃东西，六点以后停止吃东西。我觉得我就没事了。你这周末做了什么，杰森？哦。所以我的脖子，天哪。什么？
It feels so accusatory. What'd you do this week? No, I was worried because Will and I went to... Sean and I did too. We did back-to-back dinner parties. Yeah, we were just wondering where you were. With your wife and without you. Well, that's right.
感觉好有质问意味。你这周做了什么？不，我很担心，因为威尔和我去了……肖恩和我也是。我们连着办了两场晚宴。对，我们只是想你在哪。带着你老婆而没有你。嗯，没错。
Yeah, wait, where was I? Well, Sunday night, I went to the Ram game at SoFi Stadium, and then Saturday night... Oh, I had to babysit Saturday night because Amanda had a girl's night, and so we couldn't go where you guys were. How was where I missed? Was it fun?
对，等等，我在哪？好吧，周日晚上，我去索菲体育场看公羊队的比赛，然后周六晚上……哦，我周六晚上得当临时保姆，因为阿曼达有个闺蜜之夜，所以我们不能去你们去的地方。我错过的那地方怎么样？好玩吗？
Fantastic. Really fun. I'll bet. Really fun. And Sean, you know, we talk a lot about Tracy. Sean got to hang out with my sister two nights in a row. My sister Shanley. Yeah, she's fantastic.
太棒了。真的很好玩。我敢说。真的很好玩。而且肖恩，你知道的，我们经常聊起特蕾西。肖恩连续两个晚上跟我姐姐一起玩。我姐姐香利。对，她太棒了。
Shanley. Shanley. Yeah, I love her. Immediate connection. Yeah, I know. She loves Sean too. Her voice is low as yours almost, Will. Almost, I know.
香利。香利。对，我爱她。马上就很合得来。对，我知道。她也很喜欢肖恩。她的声音跟你几乎一样低，威尔。差不多，我知道。
Really cool. She wanted me to tell you, Sean, that for a little while, she was the voice of Jarlsburg cheese in the tri-state area, true story. Yeah, no, she mentioned that to me. True story. She mentioned that to me, yeah, of course.
真的很酷。她让我告诉你，肖恩，她在三州地区曾有一段时间是杰斯堡奶酪的广告配音，真的。对，不，她跟我提过这事。真的。她确实跟我提过这事，对，当然。
Did she ever want to get into acting? No, that was it, the one and done. No, she just wanted to get into Jarlsburg cheese. I mean, that was good. Topped out at Jarlsburg, that'll do it. You know. She got some cheese, she's all good. So voiceover runs in the family, huh?
她有没有想过涉足表演？没，就那一次，干完就完了。不，她只想涉足杰斯堡奶酪。我的意思是，那挺好。巅峰就是杰斯堡，这就够了。你知道。她吃到了奶酪，她好得很。所以配音这事是在家族里遗传的，哈？
She did it for a minute. My dad claims that if anything happens to me, that he'll take over my gigs. He's got a low voice. Which is, by the way, kind of a shitty thing to say to your son. Like that's what you're thinking about if something happens to me.
她干了一会儿。我爸声称，如果我出了什么事，他会接替我的工作。他嗓音很低。顺便说一句，对你儿子说这种话挺操蛋的。就像如果我出了事，你脑子里想的就是这个。
When you die, son, don't worry, I'll take care of your sons. No. I'll take your gig. Yeah, I'll take your gigs. Yeah, that makes sense. Does he have a low voice like you? No.
当你死了，儿子，别担心，我会照顾你的儿子。不。我会接替你的工作。对，我会接替你的工作。对，这倒合理。他嗓音也像你一样低吗？不。
He does. Jim Arnett's got a low voice. Jim Arnett's a good guy though. I'll tell you what, we haven't given him a name. You say that like you're trying to counter what you've heard people saying about him. Chatter, there's chatter about dad. No, you know what?
他有。吉姆·阿内特的嗓音很低。不过吉姆·阿内特是个好人。我跟你说，我们还没给他起个名字。你这么说，好像是在试图反驳你听到的别人对他的评价。闲话，有关于老爸的闲话。不，你知道吗？
He's the most equitable guy I know, he's a very... What a lovely thing to say about your father. What a sweetheart you are. It runs deep, it runs deep. It's true, listen, we gotta get to our guests because we have a really, we got a hot ticket guest hiding behind something blurry. And we got a guy here, we got a guy.
他是我认识的最公正的人，他非常……多可爱的话来形容你父亲。你真是个小甜甜。这感情很深，很深。真的，听着，我们得请出我们的嘉宾了，因为我们有一个重量级嘉宾藏在某种模糊的东西后面。我们这有个家伙，我们这有个家伙。
You both, I think no. And I think that as I intro him, it's gonna give it away pretty quick. He's from the New York areas, in the New York state region. Andrew Dice Clay. He's got a size 13 shoe according to him. He once got in a bar bra with Vince Vaughn.
你们俩，我想猜不到。而且我觉得当我介绍他时，很快就会泄露天机。他来自纽约地区，纽约州地区。安德鲁·戴斯·克雷。据他自己说，他穿13码的鞋。他曾经和文斯·沃恩在酒吧打过架。
He was briefly, he was in band of brothers. Let me see if this helps. His ear was pierced by Harrison Ford. What? He's got his own Ben and Jerry's ice cream. He once pulled an all-nighter with David Wells who then went out and pitched a no-hitter the next day. Is this James Fallon?
他短暂地参演过《兄弟连》。我看看这有没有帮助。他的耳朵是被哈里森·福特穿孔的。什么？他有自己的本杰瑞冰淇淋。他曾经和大卫·韦尔斯熬过通宵，而后者第二天出去投出了一场无安打比赛。这是詹姆斯·法伦吗？
Sean, you're right. No, no, no, no. It's James Fallon. It's Jimmy Fallon. Oh, Jimmy Fallon. Woo-hoo! It is so great to be here on this show. And we, she's done research
肖恩，你猜对了。不，不，不，不。是詹姆斯·法伦。是吉米·法伦。哦，吉米·法伦！呜呼！很高兴能来到这个节目。而我们，她做了研究
and they found that the funniest thing is smart list. And so last night I was in a laboratory and it mixed with my vocal cords. And so I sound like this now and the embassy loves it. It's the new voice of the Tonight Show. And it looked kind of a little bit like Sean and Jason put together, maybe, with him.
然后他们发现最搞笑的事就是 smart list。所以昨晚我在一个实验室里，它和我的声带融合了。所以我现在听起来是这样的，大使馆很喜欢它。这是《今夜秀》的新声音。而且他看起来有点像肖恩和杰森结合在一起，也许吧，和他一起。
And don't even really sound, I don't even really sound like Will. By the way, I can't even hear the impressionist. By the way, I love it. Was the impression close? It was pretty close. Yeah, and you do good impressions. Yeah, you do good impressions.
而且听起来真的不太像，我听起来真的不太像威尔。顺便说一句，我甚至听不出模仿者的声音。顺便说一句，我很喜欢。这个模仿像吗？挺像的。对，你很擅长模仿。对，你很擅长模仿。
For reals. Yeah, mind-blowing impressions. What's your best impersonation? You know, it's so funny because it dates me, but I used to do John Travolta from Greece. That was my best one. Did you audition with that for SNL? Because don't you have to do one or two?
真的。对，令人惊叹的模仿。你最拿手的模仿是什么？你知道，这太搞笑了，因为这暴露了我的年龄，但我以前模仿过《油脂》里的约翰·特拉沃尔塔。那是我的拿手绝活。你当时用那个去周六夜现场试镜了吗？因为你不是得准备一两个吗？
How does it go? Well, hang on, we'll let him hear. He's warming up. Yeah, yeah, just feel it. Hey, you want me to come in? Yeah. I usually close with Travolta. All right, you want me to open?
那是怎么样的？好吧，等一下，我们让他听听。他在热身。对，对，感受一下。嘿，你想让我上吗？好。我通常以特拉沃尔塔收尾。好吧，你想让我开场吗？
Come in hot. It's like, Sam, did you, I swear to God, can't believe this thing. I mean, what's going on? Right, Sam, I can't believe I'm in high school. These are what kids look like in high school. Like, we're all 40-year-old kids. Do you guys get the new copy of AARP magazine?
火爆开场。就像，萨姆，你，我发誓，简直不敢相信这事。我的意思是，怎么回事？对，萨姆，我不敢相信我在上高中。这就是高中里小屁孩的样子。就像，我们全都是40岁的小屁孩。你们拿到新一期的 AARP 杂志了吗？
I got to get my prostate checked, so I can't believe this. It's like, we're all in high school kids. That's very good. Wait, that's hilarious. Wait, Will, who did you say Jimmy Fallon got in a bar brawl with? Vince Vaughn. No, I don't know that story.
我得去检查前列腺了，所以我简直不敢相信。就像，我们全都是高中生小孩。这非常好。等等，太搞笑了。等等，威尔，你刚才说吉米·法伦跟谁在酒吧打过架？文斯·沃恩。不，我不知道这个故事。
Tell me that. I don't know that. All right, so it was with me and Vince on the same side. Oh, all right, because I was going to say, that's a tough fight to win. Because Bateman almost got in a fight with Vince Vaughn years ago. That's a true story, and I had to break him up.
跟我讲讲。我不知道。好吧，当时我和文斯在同一边。哦，好吧，因为我刚想说，那是一场很难打赢的仗。因为贝特曼几年前差点跟文斯·沃恩打起来。这是真的，我还得去拉架。
No, I would have run away from that. Yeah, he's a big dude. He's a tough dude, but he's a tough dude. So he was hosting SNL, and we went to a bar with everybody, like the cast, and we were drinking, and we went to Hurley's bar, which is not even here anymore. I think now it's a Magnolia Bakery. And we went into this bar, and I'm at the urinal next to Vince,
不，我会从那跑开的。对，他是个大块头。他是个狠角色，但确实是个狠角色。所以他当时在主持《周六夜现场》，我们跟所有人一起去了一个酒吧，比如演员阵容，我们在喝酒，我们去了赫利酒吧，那个酒吧现在甚至都不在了。我想现在那里是一家木兰面包店。我们走进这个酒吧，我在挨着文斯的小便池旁，
and he goes, hey, Jimmy, Will is in the stall. Let's just kick open the door and just fool around, and just, you know, surprise. Feral, feral. Well, feral, yeah. So I go, oh, hilarious, go for it. So Vince turns around, he kicks the stall open, whoops, kicks it, and it's not Will Feral.
他说，嘿，吉米，威尔在隔间里。我们把门踹开，逗逗他，然后，你知道，吓他一跳。野蛮，野蛮。嗯，野蛮，对。所以我说，哦，太搞笑了，上吧。于是文斯转过身，把隔间的门一脚踹开，哎呀，踹开了，里面根本不是威尔·法瑞尔。
Oh, my gosh. Just some dude. You mother, dude, they started throwing. I'm zipping up my zipper. I'm like, what the, dude, we just started throwing punches. It was crazy. Everyone got split up. I go, what in the world?
哦，天哪。就只是个路人。你他妈的，老兄，他们开始动起手来。我正拉上拉链。我都懵了，老兄，我们直接开始挥拳了。太疯狂了。所有人都被拉开了。我说，这到底是怎么回事？
And Will was just outside on his phone. He was not in the stall. Just saying my bad. Yeah, we got thrown out of the bar, and I think we went to another one. We went to another bar to talk about it. What do you think? Imagine if you did that today, it would be just over.
而威尔当时正站在外面打电话。他根本不在隔间里。只是说我的错。对，我们被赶出了酒吧，我想我们又去了另一家。我们去了另一家酒吧谈论这事。你们觉得呢？想象一下如果你今天这么干，那就彻底完蛋了。
Yeah, double cancellation. It wouldn't even be page six, it'd be the cover of the post, right? It'd be the cover of the post, for sure. Are you kidding? They're waiting for that. Jimmy. Wait a second, Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy. So many millions of questions.
对，双重取消。甚至都不会上第六页，会直接上《纽约邮报》的头版，对吧？绝对会是《纽约邮报》的头版。开什么玩笑？他们正等着呢。吉米。等一下，吉米，吉米，吉米，吉米。有数百万个问题。
First of all, you're an all-time hilarious guy. You're one of those dudes, man. You just always have made me laugh. I think you're super, super funny. And you kind of burst onto the scene. You came onto SNL. How old were you when you started in SNL? Five years old.
首先，你是个历史级别的搞笑大咖。你是那种人，老兄。你总是能逗笑我。我觉得你超级超级搞笑。而且你算是突然崭露头角。你加入了《周六夜现场》。你进《周六夜现场》时多大？五岁。
Wow, we're five years old. A child, yeah. Is that the youngest cast member ever? Yeah, I was on, I think Eddie Murphy was the youngest. I think he was like 18 or something. No way. I was 23 when I got SNL. That's crazy.
哇，我们五岁。还是个孩子，对。那是史上最年轻的演员吗？对，我当时在，我想埃迪·墨菲是最年轻的。我想他当时大概18岁左右。不会吧。我进《周六夜现场》时23岁。太疯狂了。
23, and then how long after starting SNL did you get on Weekend Update? That was probably, I stayed for six seasons, so I'd probably say three, three or four seasons later. And I didn't want to stay past three seasons. I wanted to leave the show on good terms. And where did you want to go? What ideally was going to be the next step?
23岁，然后加入《周六夜现场》多久后你去了“周末更新”？那大概是，我在那呆了六季，所以我可能会说三、四季之后。而且我不想呆过三季。我想以良好的关系离开这个节目。那你当时想去哪？理想情况下下一步是什么？
I don't know. Straight actor? Yeah, I think movies was in my brain. I want to be a good, yeah. I thought in my head, pollution. You only did six seasons of SNL? Yeah. Wow, it seems longer.
我不知道。正剧演员？对，我想电影在我的脑海里。我想成为一个优秀的好，对。我脑子里想的是，垃圾车司机。你只拍了六季《周六夜现场》？对。哇，感觉时间更长。
I know it does. In a great way, in a great way. Chevy only did one, one season. No way. And Marty Short did one. Wow. Marty only did one too, huh? Yeah.
我知道是的。以一种很棒的方式，以一种很棒的方式。切维只拍了一季。不会吧。马丁·肖特也只拍了一季。哇。马丁也只拍了一季，是吗？对。
Only one. Where does the passion for acting and movies sit for you? I mean, you must be completely satisfied with the upgrade that you've made to the career you've had since. I mean, you've got yourself a nice routine. I love it, yeah. I love this. I didn't even know this was an option, to be honest.
只拍了一季。你对表演和电影的热情现在处于什么位置？我的意思是，对于你之后职业生涯的升级，你肯定完全满意吧。我的意思是，你给自己搞了一套不错的日常。我很喜欢，对。我很喜欢这个。老实说，我甚至不知道这还是个选项。
So I wouldn't even dream for Tonight Show hosting. I didn't know this was a possibility. So this is great. I get to do bits every day and dress up and act. I could do, every day is a new, different, fun thing. Jimmy, how do you know you made it? Is it the aquarium? In the background.
所以我连做梦都没想过主持《今夜秀》。我不知道这有可能。所以这太棒了。我每天都能表演小品、盛装打扮、演戏。我可以做，每天都是崭新的、不同的、有趣的事。吉米，你怎么知道你成功了？是因为那个水族馆吗？在背景里。
He's got an aquarium in the background. Are you in Lauren's office? Is that Lauren's? Yeah, I'm renting out Lauren's. It's like an Airbnb. It's like, it's called Offi B&B. And you share someone's office. You look online, you'd be surprised.
他背景里有个水族馆。你在洛恩的办公室吗？那是洛恩的吗？对，我租了洛恩的。就像爱彼迎（Airbnb）一样。就像，这叫办公彼迎（Offi B&B）。然后你和别人共用一个办公室。你在网上看，你会大吃一惊的。
There's so many offices. And they have just a futon or a pullout. Yeah, yeah. There's a Murphy bed that I didn't, if it could only tell stories, you know what I'm saying? Of course. From the 70s. Oh my gosh.
有那么多办公室。而且它们只有一张沙发床或者折叠床。对，对。有一张墨菲床，我不知道，如果它会讲故事的话，你知道我在说什么吗？当然。从70年代开始的。噢天哪。
But yeah, I'm at Lauren's office. He's not here. Well, you know, Saturday night, he comes in late. He doesn't really come in during the day. So I just take it over. I'm not gonna use it. He might as well take it. Why, why use it when there's other places to use?
不过对啦，我在洛恩的办公室。他不在那。好吧，你知道的，周六晚上，他会来得很晚。他白天其实不怎么来。所以我直接接管了。我又不用它。他不用白不用。为什么不用呢，既然有别的地方可以用？
You know, Danny and Steve, they would use other places. I'll go over to Danny's or I'll go to Steve's. Maybe Paul's. Guess which Paul? Paul Schaffer. Guess which? Wrong. Paul Simon.
你知道的，丹尼和史蒂夫，他们会去别的地方。我要去丹尼那或者去史蒂夫那。也许去保罗那。猜猜哪个保罗？保罗·谢弗。猜猜哪个？猜错。保罗·麦克、保罗·西蒙。
Wrong. It's McCartney, anyway. Let's play Guess Which Paul. It's so funny. I love your show, by the way. I know this show isn't about you guys, obviously, but it really is. I heard about it and I heard how funny it is.
猜错。反正就是麦卡特尼。我们来玩猜猜哪个保罗吧。太搞笑了。顺便说一句，我很喜欢你们的节目。我知道这个节目显然不是关于你们的，但它确实是。我听说过这个节目，也听说它有多搞笑。
I go, I gotta listen to this thing. It is unbelievably addictive. And I love your show. I love the way you guys are interested in people and have a conversation and a flow and it's fun. And I'm doing it now and I'm actually telling everybody, it is real and it's so good. I also know when there's guests that wanna get out of there
我说，我得听听这个。这节目简直让人欲罢不能。我很喜欢你们的节目。我喜欢你们对人感兴趣、能进行对话、很有默契而且很有趣的方式。我现在正在做这个，而且我实际上在告诉所有人，这是真的，而且太棒了。我也知道当有嘉宾想离开的时候
and they're like, yeah, we gotta go. You know that feeling. Yeah, let's just do another commercial for something. And the commercial's funnier than the guest. But I actually was listening to you and I loved this conversation so much and I'm wearing my AirPods. I forgot who the guest was, but you guys are so funny.
他们就会说，行吧，我们得走了。你懂那种感觉。对，让我们再插播一个广告吧。而且广告比嘉宾还要搞笑。但我当时真的在听你们节目，我太喜欢这个对话了，我戴着 AirPods。我忘了嘉宾是谁了，但你们太搞笑了。
And my AirPods fell out of my ear. I think I have a loose ear hole. And it just fell out of my ear and I didn't go back to pick it up. I left the AirPods in the street. What? Is that true? It's deep.
然后我的 AirPods 从耳朵里掉了下来。我觉得我的耳洞有点松。它就从我耳朵里掉出来了，我都没回去捡。我把 AirPods 留在大街上了。什么？真的吗？太离谱了。
I know, but the traffic was coming. Someone recognized me. Yeah, how do you deal with that? You're incredibly high profile. What are you doing crossing the street in New York? Do you get stopped left and right? If you don't pay somebody across the street for you. Come on, let's go in.
我知道，但车流正开过来。有人认出了我。对，你平时怎么应对这种情况？你知名度太高了。你在纽约过马路都在干什么？你是不是走一步就被拦下来？除非你花钱雇个人帮你在前面开路。得了吧，我们进去吧。
I do that as well. But you know, they're the ones wearing my Fitbit and all that stuff. So I can like, oh, we got my steps in. Like, hey. Now, how good are you with, you know, cause everyone's got a camera phone. Are you pretty good about stopping and taking pictures
我也这么干。但你知道，他们才戴着我的 Fitbit 手环那些东西。所以我可以像，哦，我们完成今天的步数了。嘿。话说回来，面对大家都有拍照手机这事，你应付得怎么样？你很擅长停下来拍照
or do you have a line that gets you past it all? I take pictures of everybody. I don't care. Yeah. Yeah, he does. I've seen Jimmy in action. He's very, he's very, you are truly a person, a guy of the people.
还是你有一套能帮你应付过去的台词？我都跟每个人拍照。我不在乎。对。对，他会的。我见识过吉米大显身手。他非常，非常，你真的是一个亲民的人。
You give a lot of time to people. People stop you on a picture. You're like, yeah, you're like, every time. And Sean's very much the same way. I do that. You should see, he does 30, 40 selfies a day. I actually ask to have a picture. Even if they're walking the other direction.
你花了很多时间陪大家。人们拦住你拍照。你就说，行，你就像，每次都这样。肖恩也是这样的人。我也会这样。你瞧瞧他，他一天拍30到40张自拍。我甚至会主动要求拍张照。哪怕他们正朝相反方向走。
Hey, hey, hey, hey. You didn't get your picture. You trying to hurt my feelings? You didn't get your, are you trying to hurt my feelings? I remember when I was in Lauren's office and Conan had just announced that he's leaving late night. And then I want to say, this is true.
嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿。你还没拍照呢。你想伤害我的感情吗？你没拍，你是想伤害我的感情吗？我还记得我在洛恩的办公室时，柯南刚刚宣布他要离开深夜秀。然后我想说，这是真的。
But I want to say in six years, he was taking over the tonight show. Like it was something weird like that. Like in six years I've taken over. So Lauren was, and I was leaving SNL. And Lauren goes, would you have interest in hosting late night, taking over for Conan? And I was like, maybe not really.
但我只想说，六年里他将接手《今夜秀》。就像是有那种奇怪的事情。就像六年里我接手了。所以洛恩当时，而我要离开《周六夜现场》。洛恩说，你有没有兴趣主持深夜秀，接替柯南？然后我说，也许吧，其实不太感兴趣。
I don't know. What? I think I'm just gonna do movies. And Tina Fey was there and she's like, you'd be fantastic. You're gonna be talk to everybody. You talk to people in the street. You just stop, you go to bars, you're Irish, you're chatty.
我不知道。什么？我想我还是去拍电影吧。蒂娜·菲当时也在，她说，你会表现得很棒的。你会和每个人聊天。你在街上跟人聊天。你一言不合就停下来，你去酒吧，你是爱尔兰人，你很健谈。
You're totally, this is totally a good job. And then six years later, my movie career in the dumper. Dumper? Yeah, sure, sure. Will had three callbacks for the voice of dumper. And you cry, everybody, it's made dumper. Well, that's not right, because it's a voice of dumper. I was corning something.
你完全，这绝对是个好工作。然后六年之后，我的电影生涯跌入谷底。谷底？对，当然，当然。威尔为了垃圾车司机的配音试镜了三次。你哭了，所有人，它成了垃圾车司机。好吧，那不对，因为那是垃圾车司机的配音。我当时在胡编。
By the way, my 11 year old last night, Abel says to me, he and Archie and I were talking, and he goes, we're talking about middle school. And he goes out of the blue. He kind of thinks for a second and he goes, middle school sucks. Hi, that's my best friend, Gordon. He's kind of a dork.
顺便说一句，我11岁的儿子昨晚，阿贝尔对我说，他和阿奇还有我在聊天，然后他突然说。他想了一会儿然后说，初中糟透了。嗨，那是我的好朋友戈登。他有点像个书呆子。
And so am I. And this is the story of my kind of terrible life. Like he did an intro for a fake movie about a middle schooler. Unprompted, just sitting in the back seat. Unprompted, out of the blue. It was so funny. I was like, what is this?
我也是。这就是我有点糟糕的人生故事。就像他为一部关于初中生的假电影做了一个开场白。没头没脑的，就坐在后座上。没头没脑，突发奇想。太搞笑了。我就想，这是什么？
Was Abel, who sat behind the desk when he was a baby? That's Archie. I got a picture of Archie at the old late night with Jimmy. And I'm under the desk holding Archie's, what, maybe a year? Yeah, baby. Yeah, total baby. I'm holding in place and Jimmy's sitting in the guest chair laughing and Archie's in the host behind the desk
阿贝尔是不是小时候坐在桌子后面的那个？那是阿奇。我有一张阿奇在吉米老版深夜秀的照片。我蹲在桌子底下，抱着阿奇的，什么，可能一岁？对，婴儿。对，完全是个婴儿。我抱着他，吉米坐在嘉宾椅子上大笑，而阿奇坐在主持人桌子后面
and Jimmy's chair. It's so great. It's such a great pic. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Hey, Jimmy, let me ask you something. Do you feel like, because you work more than anybody, I just, there's gotta be some days where just like,
和吉米的椅子上。太棒了。这照片太棒了。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。嘿，吉米，我问你个事。你觉得，因为你比任何人都努力工作，我只是觉得，总会有一些日子你会觉得，
I cannot do this. Like how do you get through those rough days? At this point, I think I'm over. I mean, you just, you don't get sick. I mean, I actually just, I look forward to it. I actually still enjoy it. I'm still at the years where I'm actually curious and I know that every day will be a little different.
我做不下去了。比如你是怎么熬过那些艰难日子的？到了这个时候，我觉得我已经度过了。我是说，你就是，你不会生病。我是说，实际上，我只是很期待。我其实还是很享受。我正处在这样的年纪，我实际上充满了好奇，而且我知道每一天都会有所不同。
Something will be, it's actually perfect for me. Perfect for my brain. Because it's not the same people. And what's the schedule? Do you take, is there a pattern that you take off every single month or is it? It changes, you know, it's like, but I think we probably do 200 something shows a year.
总会有一些，这实际上对我来说太完美了。对我的大脑来说太完美了。因为不是同一群人。那时间表是怎样的？你有没有安排每个月固定休息一段时间，还是说？这经常变，你知道的，但我想我们一年大概做200多期节目。
That's part of, that's the contract. Here's what blows my mind. When Will and Grace did that reboot in, I don't know, 2017 or something, we, you were kind enough to have this on your show and we did this huge musical number. And this is what blew my mind. We showed up and you walked on to the stage
那是其中一部分，那是合同规定的。最让我震惊的是这个。当《威尔和格蕾丝》在，我不知道，2017年左右重启时，我们，你很友善地邀请我们上了你的节目，我们做了一个超大的音乐歌舞段落。而最让我震惊的是这个。我们到了现场，你走到舞台上
and you were like, great, everybody ready? Great, let's do it. And you knew it, like in one rehearsal, you're like, got it, everybody good? Great. And I was like, how can he, how does your brain work where you do one run through of a huge fucking thing?
然后你说，太好了，大家都准备好了吗？太好了，我们开始吧。你就全记住了，就排练了一次，你就说，懂了，大家都好了吗？太好了。然后进行下一个。我就想，怎么会这样，你的大脑是怎么运作的，你排练一遍这么大个的破玩艺儿？
And you're like, great, got it. On to the next. It's unbelievable to watch. I think that one too. I think we probably rehearsed maybe before you guys got there just to make sure, cause you were, that was a big get for us. But still.
然后你就说，太好了，懂了。进入下一个。看你这样简直难以置信。我也这么觉得。我想我们可能在你们到那之前排练过一次，只是为了确保万无一失，因为你们对我们来说是个大咖。但依然。
But that was a fun bit too. Well, it should be. It was, it was a big deal. But we did love it, but you know, we'd like to take big swings and, you know, I think from Saturday Night Live, you just know that when the light turns on, you gotta do it and the show goes on.
但那段也挺有趣的。好吧，本来就该有趣。那是个大事件。但我们确实很喜欢，不过你知道的，我们喜欢搞大动作，而且，我觉得从《周六夜现场》出来的经历让你知道，当灯光亮起时，你必须开工，节目必须继续。
But your brain must be like in that mode of like, just one step ahead of everybody that you're working around, just so you can stay on your toes and think about what's coming next. I mean, you must have, your brain must be trained to think that way. Yeah.
但你的大脑肯定处于那种状态，就是永远比你周围合作的人快一步，好让你能保持机敏，思考接下来要发生什么。我的意思是，你的大脑一定受过这种思维方式的训练。对。
I'm sorry, I wasn't listening. That's it. I was listening. I wasn't listening either. Let me ask you this. Is there an opposite that you have to go to to balance it out? Like, do you ever get super quiet for a day or two?
不好意思，我刚才没听。就是这样。我有在听。我刚才也没听。我问你个事。有没有相反的事情是你必须去做的，来平衡一下？比如，你有没有哪一两天变得超级安静？
Like, what do the weekends look like? Yeah. I mean, well, weekends are kids, you know, lots of, I have two little girls now. It's like, but yeah, anytime, I mean, my favorite thing to do is do nothing at all and just not, I love hanging out with my wife and, you know, that was a good call.
比如，周末是什么样的？对。我是说，好吧，周末就是陪孩子，你知道的，有好多，我现在有两个小女儿。就像，不过对啦，随时，我是说，我最喜欢的事情就是什么都不做，就是不，我喜欢和我老婆一起闲逛，你知道的，那是个好主意。
And so I- By the way, it'd be so great, like anniversary dinner and like you guys, just the two of you, you look at me, you're just gonna be eating, having a nice glass of wine. You look up across the light candle and you just go, hey, I just wanted to say, this was a good call. That's too far from what happens.
所以我——顺便说一句，这该有多棒啊，比如结婚纪念日晚餐，然后你们俩，就你们俩，你看着我，你们正吃着东西，喝着一杯美酒。你抬头透过烛光看着对方，然后说，嘿，我只是想说，这真是个好主意。这跟实际发生的事差太远了。
But I do like that. You know, I just, quiet, you know, is my favorite. I can do that and I'm very happy doing nothing. I'm not an adventurous, really crazy, I have to be out all the time. I don't really like more than four people at a dinner. Yeah, right. That's a good rule.
但我确实喜欢那样。你知道，安静，你知道的，是我的最爱。我能做到这一点，而且什么都不做让我非常快乐。我不是那种喜欢冒险、真的很疯狂、必须一直出门的人。吃晚饭时我真的不喜欢超过四个人。对，没错。这是个好规则。
What about the kids? Do they give you room for that? Or are they always like, let's go, Dave, let's go, let's go, let's go, funny face, get on the floor, on your knees, let's play. Yeah. Yeah, I let the nannies raise them. I haven't seen my kids in three years,
那孩子们呢？他们会给你留出这个空间吗？还是他们总是说，走吧，戴夫，走吧，走吧，走吧，做个鬼脸，趴到地上，跪下来，我们玩吧。对。对，我让保姆把他们抚养长大。我已经三年没见过我的孩子们了，
but they sent me pictures and stuff and they're well fed. Oh, that sounds nice. There's FaceTime. Yeah, and they're like, they're learning like some new type of like jiu-jitsu, like it's like a new thing. It's like, yeah. Are they here in the country?
但他们会给我发照片啥的，而且他们都吃得很饱。哦，听起来不错。还有 FaceTime。对，他们就像，他们在学某种新流派的柔术，像是新玩意儿。就像，对。他们现在在这个国家吗？
Sorry, we should, are they actually in the US? What do you, what do you call the country? Okay, good. Continental, continental US. Continental US, we're gonna. Yeah, no, okay, no. No, no, we don't want to. Are they in any of the territories?
抱歉，我们应该，他们真的在美国吗？你把，你管这叫什么国家？好吧，很好。美国本土。美国本土，我们要。对，不，好吧，不。不，不，我们不想。他们在任何领地里吗？
Well, if you have a risk board, I can show you exactly where they are. Who's tonight's guest? Tonight's guest is a, we're doing a fun bit tonight. We didn't tell anyone, but tonight's guest is Will Ferrell, but the real truth is Jimmy Kimmel's guest tonight is Ryan Reynolds, but we're doing a trick and Ryan Reynolds is coming on my show
如果你有《风险》游戏棋盘，我可以确切地指给你看他们在哪。今晚的嘉宾是谁？今晚的嘉宾是，我们今晚有个好玩的环节。我们没告诉任何人，但今晚的嘉宾是威尔·法瑞尔，但真正的事实是吉米·金梅尔今晚的嘉宾是瑞安·雷诺兹，但我们在搞一个恶作剧，瑞安·雷诺兹要上我的节目
and Will is going on Jimmy Kimmel. You guys. I mean, as they come out? Yeah, so no one knows. No one knows that Ryan's coming out. And, and Rudd is doing a Colbert. Yeah, oh yeah. Rudd is doing Col, yeah.
而威尔要上吉米·金梅尔的节目。你们这群人。我是说，在他们出场的时候？对，所以没人知道。没人知道瑞安要出场。而且，雷德在做斯蒂芬·科拜尔的节目。对，哦对。雷德在做科，对。
And Gal Gadot is doing Jimmy or a Corden. Oh, wait, Jason, how do you know all of that? Jason doesn't know what he's talking about. But by the way, Jimmy's looking up on the board. He's like, yeah, Rudd, he's got Rudd's schedule on the wall. Yeah. I do have Rudd. Rudd is coming on with, with Will really soon,
还有盖尔·加朵在做吉米的节目或者柯登的节目。哦，等等，杰森，你怎么知道这一切的？杰森根本不知道自己在说什么。不过顺便说一句，吉米正在看板子。他就好像，对，雷德，他把雷德的日程表贴在墙上了。对。我确实有雷德。雷德要和，和威尔一起来，
like next week, not weird. This might be a really interesting tidbit or a really boring one. Q, these guys know nothing. We'll wait. I'm doing a play that opens in Chicago called Good Night Oscar. And I play Oscar Levant.
就下周，不奇怪吗？这可能是一个非常有趣的花絮，也可能是一个极其无聊的花絮。Q，这群家伙什么都不知道。等一下。我在演一出即将在芝加哥首演的话剧叫《晚安，奥斯卡》。我饰演奥斯卡·莱万特。
Oscar Levant was George Gershwin's best friend. And Oscar gets, ended up in Insane Asylums. And it's his crazy story. Dictated prescription pills and amazing pianist and super funny. And one of the tonight shows frequent guests cause he was so funny. And Oscar, the play takes place and Oscar gets a pass
奥斯卡·莱万特是乔治·格什温的好朋友。而奥斯卡最后进了精神病院。这是他疯狂的故事。靠处方药维系，是个惊人的钢琴家，超级搞笑。也是《今夜秀》的常客之一，因为他太搞笑了。而奥斯卡，这出话剧的故事背景是奥斯卡获得了通行证
to come from the Insane Asylum to appear with Jack Parr on the tonight show. And then as soon as the segment's over, he has to go back to the Insane Asylum. It's loosely based on a true incident. But I don't know if you've ever seen Oscar on the tonight show, but he's hilarious. No, I've never seen this or even heard the story.
得以离开精神病院，与杰克·帕尔一同亮相《今夜秀》。然后一旦这个环节结束，他就得立刻返回精神病院。这是大致根据真实事件改编的。但我不知道你们有没有看过奥斯卡上《今夜秀》，但他太搞笑了。不，我从来没看过，甚至没听过这个故事。
He did the appearance and then went back to the asylum? Yeah, yeah. Oh my God. And are you, who are you playing? I play Oscar Levant. The asylum. Oh, you do? I play the asylum.
他出场亮相之后又回了精神病院？对，对。哦天哪。那你，你在演谁？我演奥斯卡·莱万特。精神病院。哦，真的吗？我演精神病院。
And is that scene in the play? Yeah, the whole play takes place backstage of the tonight show and then on the tonight show. No way. Who plays Jack Parr? I, maybe somebody, but we don't know yet. Oh, you're in negotiations. You can't speak about it because you're such a high profile person.
那场戏在话剧中吗？对，整部话剧都发生在《今夜秀》的后台，然后在《今夜秀》上。不会吧。谁演杰克·帕尔？我，也许有人演，但我们还不知道。哦，你还在谈判中。你不能说，因为你是个大人物。
I can do it. Well, hang on. I mean, you have to come in and read for the, but I'm sure we get you. Read for it. What are you talking about? I'm pretty much sure I do it every night. I mean, I could probably do it.
我能演。好吧，等一下。我的意思是，你得来为这个角色试读，但我确信我们能搞定你。为它试读。你在说什么？我几乎可以肯定我每晚都在演。我的意思是，我大概能演。
But let me say, but the point of me saying all that, isn't it crazy that you are part of such a gigantic legacy? I know people, I know you've thought of it and then people commented on it all the time, but it's wild to know you and to know that you have succeeded all of these huge iconic hosts of this institution. And now you are one of them. Yeah, the tonight show, Jimmy, did you ever,
但容我说一句，我说这一切的重点难道不疯狂吗？你竟然是这样一个巨大遗产的一部分。我知道人们，我知道你想过这个，然后人们也经常对它评头论足，但能认识你并知道你接替了所有这些这个机构里巨大而标志性的主持人，这种感觉太疯狂了。现在你成了其中之一。对，《今夜秀》，吉米，你有没有，
Sean brings up a great point. The tonight show is the, well, you always bring up good points. That's why you're the host of the year. But it is the gold standard, right? I mean, it's the tonight show is the first one. Do you remember, did you have a moment where you like, I don't know, went into a room by yourself
肖恩提出一个极好的观点。1今夜秀》是，嗯，你总是能提出精彩的观点。这就是为什么你是年度主持人。但它确实是黄金标准，对吧？我的意思是，《今夜秀》是开山鼻祖。你还记得吗，你有没有过这样一个时刻，比如，独自走进一个房间
or went to a park and went like, or looked in the mirror and went, holy shit, I'm hosting the tonight show? How many hosts have there been? Is there, are you fifth? Fourth? Yeah, something like that. I think it's, yeah, it's Steve Allen, Jack Parr. Johnny.
或者去公园里，然后，或者照着镜子说，卧槽，我在主持《今夜秀》？到现在为止有过多少位主持人？是，你是第五位？第四位？对，差不多吧。我想是，对，是史蒂夫·艾伦，杰克·帕尔。约翰尼。
Then Johnny. Then Jay. Conan. Jay. Jay. Yeah. Awful. Terrible.
然后是约翰尼。然后是杰伊。柯南。杰伊。杰伊。对。糟糕。太差劲了。
And then me, yeah, sorry. Yeah, six hosts. Wow. It is amazing. Honestly, I never thought I would do any of this stuff. I never thought I'd be on, I've started on smart list, smart list, you know? Never thought I'd be on smart list.
然后是我，对，抱歉。对，六位主持人。哇。太惊人了。老实说，我从没想过我会做这些事。我从没想过我会上，我从 smart list 开始，smart list，你知道的？从没想过我会上 smart list。
Still not sure if this is gonna make any of it. None of this is gonna be on. You're gonna have a new publicist tomorrow. I'll tell you that much. Yeah. That's the first call after this. I'll bet you're right. But I did, you know, SNL was like a big,
现在还不确定这段能不能播。这些全都不会播的。你明天就要换公关了。我跟你打包票。对。这是这之后打的第一个电话。我敢说你说得对。但我确实，你知道的，《周六夜现场》就像是一个巨大的，
that was all I ever wanted to do. That's all I dreamt about when I ever, I cut a birthday cake and closed my eyes whenever I threw a coin in a fountain. Come on. I always wished. That's true. That's amazing.
那是我唯一想做的事。那是我每当我切开生日蛋糕、每当我往喷泉里投硬币时梦想的一切。拜托。我一直都在许愿。这是真的。太惊人了。
And that was it. And then once I got there, I go, huh, like now what do I do? And then... Well, then can I ask, when you did your audition, I would imagine there's already huge nerves for that. But given that you were praying for it since you were just a little baby,
那就是全部。然后一旦我到了那里，我就想，哈，那我接下来该干嘛？然后……好吧，那我能问问，当你去试镜的时候，我想当时就已经紧张得不行了吧。但考虑到你从小到大一直在为此祈祷，
how did you even get through the audition? Were you not just paralyzed? You auditioned twice, right, Jimmy? Is that right? Yeah. Yeah, I auditioned once at this comic strip here in New York City at a comedy club. I went on stage for three minutes,
你是怎么挺过试镜的？难道你没有直接瘫痪吗？你试镜过两次，对吧，吉米？是这样吗？对。对，我第一次试镜是在纽约市的一家喜剧俱乐部的微型脱口秀场。我在舞台上呆了三分钟，
tried to get into my John Travolta impression. Didn't work. And I go, that year, they were looking for, they hired Tracy Morgan that year. So we weren't really in the same, running in the same category. So that was good for them. But I was totally depressed.
试图模仿约翰·特拉沃尔塔。没成功。我说，那一年，他们在找，他们那一年雇了特雷西·摩根。所以我们其实不在同一个，没有在同一个赛道上。这对他们来说挺好。但我当时完全陷入了抑郁。
And I was like, well, that was my shot. But then I went back, I actually moved to LA for two years. And I was taking acting lessons, but not really, but I was paying for acting lessons. And I did this thing, I took this acting class and I read somewhere that James Dean didn't ever get on stage in practice
心想，好吧，我的机会就这么没了。但我后来又回去了，我实际上搬到洛杉矶住了两年。我在上表演课，但也不是真的在学，不过我在付表演课的学费。我做了这么件事，我上了一个表演课，我在某处读到詹姆斯·迪恩从来不上台练习
and really do acting classes. So I would never participate with the class. I would just sit there and watch, because that's what James Dean did, like thinking I was James Dean. Yeah, sure. And then I studied with the groundlings. I started working with those guys.
也不真的去上表演课。所以我从不参与班上的活动。我只是坐在那看，因为詹姆斯·迪恩就是这么干的，当时还以为自己就是詹姆斯·迪恩。对，没错。然后我跟“地面lings”（The Groundlings）剧团学习。我开始和那些家伙合作。
And then, yeah, before I got the groundlings, I got the call to audition again for Star Art Live. And this time I did an impression. I did a bunch of impressions, but I did Adam Sandler. And this was at the time when no one was doing Adam Sandler. Like he was just left the cast.
然后，是的，在我加入地面灵斯之前，我接到了再次为《周六夜现场》试镜的电话。这次我模仿了一个人。我模仿了一堆人，但我模仿了亚当·桑德勒。当时正是没有人模仿亚当·桑德勒的时候。就像他刚离开演员阵容。
And so I did him and I remember, I was always getting, you get, you're right backstage on SNL. You were actually in 8-H, Studio 8-H in New York, where they make Star Art Live. I remember I took pictures of the elevator because they had NBC carpeting in the elevator. I was like, if I never come back here,
所以我模仿了他，我记得，我一直在，你在《周六夜现场》后台。你其实是在纽约的 8-H 演播室，8-H 演播室，那是制作《周六夜现场》的地方。我记得我给电梯拍了照，因为电梯里铺着 NBC 的地毯。我就想，如果我再也回不到这里了，
I want to show my kids like I was in the building, you know, and I was so excited. And they came up, the guy puts the hair and makeup, they go, hey, just let you know, you're Jimmy, right? They go, yeah, they go, Lauren doesn't really laugh. So don't let that throw you. I go, sure, that's fine. And then I went over to the guy who's putting my microphone
我想向我的孩子们展示，我当时就在大楼里，你知道的，我当时太兴奋了。然后他们走了过来，那个人弄好发型和妆容，他们说，嘿，跟你说个事，你是吉米，对吧？他们说，对，他们说，劳伦其实不怎么笑。所以别让这影响了你的状态。我说，行，没问题。然后我走向那个给我别麦克风的人
and he's like, here's your mic. He's like, hey, Jimmy, good luck. But just let you know, Lauren doesn't really laugh. So don't let that throw you. I go, okay. And then I go over, they're about to announce me and the producer goes, whoever's bringing me up, maybe it was Marcy Klein.
他就像是，这是你的麦。他就像是，嘿，吉米，祝你好运。但跟你说个事，劳伦其实不怎么笑。所以别让这影响了你的状态。我说，好吧。然后我走过去，他们正要宣布我上场，制片人就说，不管是谁把我带上去的，也许是马西·克莱恩。
She goes, just let you know, Lauren's not a big laugher. So don't let, I go, what is this guy's problem? Oh my God. He's in the comedy business. He should laugh more. So anyways, I go on stage and I do my impression. I did Adam Sandler and I was like,
她说，跟你说个事，劳伦不太爱笑。所以别让，我说，这家伙有什么毛病？我的天哪。他是干喜剧这行的。他应该多笑笑的。不管怎样，我上台了，然后我做了我的模仿。我模仿了亚当·桑德勒，我就像是，
ah, yeah, ah, yeah, ah, yeah, ah, yeah, oh, ah, yeah, oh, ah, yeah, ah, yeah, yeah. And Lauren started laughing. He started laughing and he put his head in his hands and he was laughing hard. Oh, that's great. And I go, even if I didn't get the show, I made Lauren, Michael's laugh.
啊，呀，啊，呀，啊，呀，啊，呀，噢，啊，呀，噢，啊，呀，啊，呀，呀。然后劳伦开始笑了。他开始笑了，他双手抱头，笑得前俯后仰。噢，太棒了。然后我说，就算我没得到这份工作，我也把劳伦·迈克尔斯逗笑了。
And I was like, the rest of it was slow motion. And I left and I just felt like, I just felt like I did a great job. It was so funny. That's great. Yeah, it was great. And then I got the call maybe, I want to say, it was a month later or something.
然后我就觉得，剩下的时间好像都变成了慢镜头。我离开了，我只觉得，我只觉得我表现得太棒了。太搞笑了。太棒了。对，太棒了。然后我大概在，我想说，一个月后左右接到了电话。
They took all the time. Yeah, they made me wait, yeah. So you must have thought that you didn't get it by that point. Yeah, I didn't think I got it. Actually, I was in LA. I went back to LA thinking I didn't get it. And then Lauren came to LA,
他们花了很长时间。对，他们让我等了好久，对。所以你当时一定以为自己没被选上。对，我以为我没戏了。实际上，我在洛杉矶。我回到了洛杉矶，以为自己没被选上。然后劳伦来到了洛杉矶，
he has an office in the Paramount lot, which is beautiful. I love that lot. It's so much history and it's so cool. And I went to his office and he said, Jimmy, do you wear wigs? And I go, no, I just kind of do this to my hair. He's like, no, no, I don't mean that. I just, because we want you for the show.
他在派拉蒙片场有一间办公室，非常漂亮。我很喜欢那个片场。那里有太多的历史，而且太酷了。我去了他的办公室，他对我说，吉米，你戴假发吗？我说，不，我只是把头发弄成这样。他好像说，不，不，我不是那个意思。我只是，因为我们想让你加入这个节目。
Oh, that's great. And then I was like, wow. And I was like, I promise to make you proud. I was like, I can't wait to do this. I was so excited. Wear wigs, I'll fucking make wigs if you put me on the show. But he said to me, then he started talking about the lot
噢，太棒了。然后我当时就想，哇。我当时就说，我保证不让你失望。我当时就想，我等不及要干这个了。我太兴奋了。戴假发，如果你让我上节目，我他妈连假发都自己做。但他对我说，然后他开始谈论片场
and everything, I love it. He goes, Paramount is a great lot. He's like, sometimes you can leave it. You'll see someone from Star Trek having a coffee break or something. And as we were walking, there was a Klingon having a smoke break. There was a guy dressed as a Klingon.
以及一切，我太喜欢了。他说，派拉蒙是个好片场。他说，有时候你离开时。你会看到《星际迷航》里的某个人在喝咖啡休息什么的。当我们走着的时候，有个克林贡人正在那抽烟休息。有个家伙打扮成克林贡人的样子。
Yeah, it was pretty funny to see a guy in a full, yeah. I would kill to do a season on Saturday Night Live. Will, Sean, how about you guys? I mean, wouldn't that not be a dream? Yeah, let's do a season on this one. I mean, you know what, I'm not going to be even featured. I'm going to be, I'm going to go straight to full cast. I just think that would just be such a dream.
对，看到一个家伙穿着全套，对，挺好笑的。我做梦都想在《周六夜现场》演一季。威尔，肖恩，你们呢？我是说，那难道不是个梦想吗？对，我们在这部剧里演一季吧。我是说，你知道吗，我甚至不会只是个特邀嘉宾。我要，我要直接成为全职常驻演员。我只是觉得那绝对是个梦想。
Let's make our goal to not make Lauren laugh. And I'm going to host every week. You guys have hosted, right? These guys have. I haven't, no. I did a good bit with Sean. Remember, we did our Jeffries bit. God, that was funny.
我们的目标定为不让劳伦笑。我要每周都去当主持。你们都主持过，对吧？这几位都主持过。我没有，没有。我和肖恩合作过一个很好的小品。还记得吗，我们合作的杰弗里斯小品。天哪，太搞笑了。
I was crying, laughing. Yeah. Me too. What was the bit? We should do a new segment called Talk About the Bit. Oh, yeah. All right, talk about the bit. Make a whole new podcast out of that.
我笑哭了。我也是。那是个什么小品？我们应该做一个新环节叫“谈谈那个小品”。噢，对。好吧，谈谈那个小品。用那个做一整期新播客。
Go ahead, Jimmy. I went to this, it was based on a store. I went to Barney's here in New York. And I went and I walked in, I was getting a suit. And this guy was like, you were in the wrong store. And I was like, I just want to get it. I need to get a suit or a tuxedo for something. He goes, right, you should go maybe to the second floor.
说吧，吉米。我去过这个地方，它是根据一家店改编的。我去了纽约的巴尼斯百货。我走进去，打算买一套西装。这家伙就说，你走错店了。然后我就说，我只是想买一件。我需要为某个场合买一套西装或燕尾服。他接着说，对，你也许应该去二楼。
It's like athletic wear. I go, no, no, no, I'm belonging to this floor. This is like suits, like Gucci and Hugo Boss, whatever it was there. And he goes, right, right. You're not on the right floor. Just go check out athletics or go. I was like, this is the worst experience.
那是运动服装区。我说，不，不，不，我属于这一层。这里是西装区，像古驰和雨果博斯，管他是什么牌子。然后他接着说，对，对。你没走对楼层。去看看运动装区或者走吧。我当时想，这是最糟糕的体验。
So I wanted to write a sketch about a store where they don't want customers in there. And weirdly enough, they were opening a store downtown called Jeffrey, or Jeffries or something. Yeah, yeah, yeah, on 14th Street. Yeah, very snooty. So Matt Piedmont and I wrote this sketch called Jeffrey. And Sean and I were the workers at Jeffries.
所以我很想写一个关于一家不希望顾客进来的商店的小品。说来也怪，他们在市中心开了一家叫杰弗里，或者叫杰弗里斯什么的店。对，对，对，在第14街。对，非常势利。所以我跟马特·皮德蒙特写了这个名叫《杰弗里》的小品。我和肖恩是杰弗里斯百货的员工。
And yeah, we didn't want anyone there. And then Will was the manager, right? Will was the manager. And I think what cracked us up so hard is he had, he came in, he rode in on a scooter, right? I don't think he rehearsed that. So that was his price. And then he opened a cell phone that
对，我们不希望任何人来。然后威尔是经理，对吧？威尔是经理。我想让我们笑得如此前俯后仰的原因是，他有，他出场了，他是骑着滑板车进来的，对吧？我觉得他根本没排练过。所以那是他的绝技。然后他打开了一个手机，
was the size of my pinky. The new thing, he's like, the new thing is a tiny cell phone. And it was like, he used a loop. Like what do you look at rings with? Like a monocle? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, like a monocle thing to look at his cell phone. That's the only way he could read his emails
那手机只有我的小指那么大。新潮流，他就像是，新潮流是一个迷你手机。然后他就像是，他用了一个放大镜。就像你用什么来看戒指的？像个单片眼镜？对，对，对。对，就像一个单片眼镜似的东西来看他的手机。那是他唯一能阅读电子邮件的方法
is if he used like one of his jewelers loop the thing in. And he lost it. And I laughed so hard. Dude, he's so funny. That might have been the one, did he levitate on that one? Did he have a jet pack on that one? No, no, no, no. He had one where he was like, all right, guys,
就是用他其中一个珠宝商的放大镜插在眼睛上。然后他把那东西弄丢了。我笑得太厉害了。老兄，他太搞笑了。那可能就是那个，他在那个里面腾空而起了吗？他在那个里面背了喷气背包吗？不，不，不，不。他有一个小品是这样的，好了，伙计们，
I got to go to Milan. Donatello Versace is calling me. And he had to leave and he had a harness on. And he had just run a marathon or something crazy. So he had all, he was cut up, all his crotch in his legs and everything was all cut up, his nipples from running a marathon. This is what happens when people run a marathon.
我得去米兰了。多纳泰拉·威思 Versace 在叫我。他不得不离开，而且他绑着安全带。他刚跑完马拉松还是别的什么疯狂的事。所以他浑身上下，他胯部、腿部还有全身都磨破了，跑马拉松把乳头都磨破了。这就是人们跑马拉松时发生的事。
And I remember him being in such pain, being lifted up out of that sketch. And once it was out of the camera frame, like him wincing, like, ooh, like, it was like right. The harness was right in his crotch and yanking him up. And like, bye, guys, I have to go to Milan. And they pulled him up, yanked him up. And once it was his feet were out of the camera frame,
我记得他痛得要命，被从那个小品里吊了上去。一旦离开镜头画面，他就痛苦得龇牙咧嘴，像这样，噢，就像是，没错。安全带正好勒在他的胯部，把他猛地往上一提。然后就像是，再见啦，伙计们，我得去米兰了。他们把他拉上去，猛地往上一提。一旦他的脚离开了镜头画面，
I could see his face, but like, ooh, gosh. But I love that dude. That dude is unbelievable, man. Will and unbelievable. He is just the, I was so lucky. I got to work with the best people. It was like, everyone was so nice and fun and great at improv.
我能看到他的脸，但就是，噢，天哪。但我爱死那家伙了。那家伙简直不可思议，老兄。威尔简直不可思议。他就是，我太幸运了。我有机会和最棒的人合作。就像是，每个人都那么好、那么有趣、而且即兴表演超棒。
And it was just, I was so, I lucked out. Now, speaking of the marathon, do you do any of that kind of stuff? You do any of that, you know, we're all of a certain age. So are you, are you trying to stay ahead of things and keep yourself out of the box? Yeah, I don't know what to do. I would not do a marathon.
我真的，我太走运了。说到马拉松，你们会做那种运动吗？你们会做那种，你知道的，我们都到了一定年纪了。所以你们，你们在努力保持领先地位，让自己保持活力吗？对，我不知道该怎么办。我不会去跑马拉松。
I don't think I'd rather just root for people. Yeah, but I think a treadmill, you know, I have one. Do you get on it, Amber? It doesn't sound like you have much of a relationship with it. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Jimmy, speaking of marathons, do you have any kind of ambition to match or beat Carson
我觉得我宁愿只是为别人加油。对，但我觉得跑步机，你知道的，我有一台。你上去跑吗，亚姆？听起来你和它的关系不太亲密。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中。吉米，说到马拉松，你有没有什么野心去追平或打破卡森
of doing it 30 years? The Tonight Show? I mean, what am I at now? Do it, do it. Just do it. It's just a challenge. What are you at now? How many years?
主持30年的纪录？《今夜秀》？我是说，我现在做到第几年了？做吧，做吧。只管去做。这只是个挑战。你现在做到第几年了？多少年了？
You guys daring me? Yeah, take a challenge. Beat Carson. No way. How many years? I'll do that stuff, man. I don't beat Carson. All right, let me try.
你们在激我吗？对，接受挑战。打破卡森的纪录。没门。多少年了？我会做那些事的，老兄。我打破不了卡森的纪录。好吧，让我试试。
Let me try to beat Carson. Just try a little, just try a little bit. All right, let me try. I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't want, I don't really beat Carson. You watch, I'll do it first. I'll do it first. Okay, you go, you go, you go.
让我试试打破卡森的纪录。就试一点点，就试一点点。好吧，让我试试。我不想，我不想，我不想，我不想，我不想，我其实不想打破卡森的纪录。你看好了，我先来。我先来。好吧，你来，你来，你来。
All right, let me, all right, let me, let me just take it, just a taste. Let me do it. All right, Jason, I think the kids got something. Jimmy, go ahead. Beat Carson. I think I'm doing it, well, six years or seven years now. So that's 23 more years?
好吧，让我，好吧，让我，让我拿这个，就尝一点。让我来。好吧，杰森，我觉得这孩子有点东西。吉米，上。打破卡森的纪录。我想我在做了，好吧，现在是六年或七年。所以那是还要再过23年？
Yeah. Good math. Wow. Thank you. So that would be 60 years old for me. I could probably do it. Wait a second. What?
对。数学真好。哇。谢谢。所以那样的话我就是60岁了。我大概能做到。等一下。什么？
All right. 60 years old? I'm 40. Oh, sorry. Seven years old. Yeah. I'm not good at math. Sorry, kids.
好吧。60岁？我40岁。噢，抱歉。7岁。对。我数学不好。对不起，孩子们。
They're still rolling. No, kids are listening to this, right? They're listening to our show to learn about math, Jimmy. What? Yes. Don't you know that? What? Yeah.
他们还在录音呢。不，孩子们在听这个节目，对吧？他们听我们的节目是为了学习数学，吉米。什么？是的。你不知道这个吗？什么？对。
Yeah, it's not a bit. It's, it's insane. Hey, speaking of math, Jimmy, that's my jam. That's my jam. What is that? Talk about this. What are we talking about here? When I say that's my jam, what does that mean to you?
对，这不是一个小品。这是，太疯狂了。嘿，说到数学，吉米，那是我的强项。那是我的强项。那是什么？谈谈这个。我们在这儿聊什么呢？当我说那是我的强项时，这对你意味着什么？
What is it? All the mini music games we play in the tonight show, but just Upton made it more prime time. Oh, okay. Sorry. I got wrong information. Oh, it's trying different jellies and stuff. I thought that you were, because somebody had sent me.
那是什么？我们在《今夜秀》中玩的所有迷你音乐游戏，但只是厄普顿把它做得更有黄金档节目的感觉了。噢，好吧。抱歉。我得到了错误的信息。噢，这是尝试不同的果酱之类的。我以为你是，因为有人给我发了。
A teaser. That's my jam. That is something that somebody else has done. I thought it was a sequel to That's Not Show Cheese. That's, that's my jam. Have you guys started listening to Christmas music yet? Jimmy, what's crazy is that, that song that you guys said, you guys did on SNL, that has become like a Christmas staple.
一个预告片。那是我的强项。那是别人做过的事情。我以为那是《那不是秀场乳酪》的续集。那是，那是我的强项。你们开始听圣诞音乐了吗？吉米，疯狂的是，你们说的那首歌，你们在SNL上唱的那首歌，已经成了像圣诞节必备曲目一样的东西。
Yeah. Or whatever. I'm doing it wrong. Yeah. Wait, Jimmy, how did that happen? That is so funny and so odd. Tell Tracy what you're talking about. Yeah.
对。或者别的什么。我做错了。对。等等，吉米，那是怎么发生的？太搞笑了，也太奇怪了。告诉特雷西你在说什么。对。
There's a song that we did with Horatio and Katan. And Tracy Morgan called Christmas Time is Here. And Horatio wrote it. But basically someone sent me a tiny guitar for Christmas. My agent, I think. And it was this tiny little guitar that called a backpacker. Like I would ever backpack with a guitar. I don't know when you need it.
有一首歌是我们和霍雷肖、卡坦还有特雷西·摩根一起做的，叫《圣诞节到了》。是霍雷肖写的。但基本上有人送了我一把迷你吉他作为圣诞礼物。我想是我的经纪人。那是一把很小的吉他，叫做背包客吉他。就好像我背着吉他去背包旅行一样。我不知道你什么时候会需要它。
When you're on the treadmill probably. Exactly. So I'm having the back. So they had this tiny guitar and Horatio was just laughing at it. And he was like, what can we do with this thing? So he just started playing like. And then I had this keyboard in my office that had pre-recorded drum beats on it and loops.
大概在跑步机上的时候吧。完全正确。所以我背着。所以他们有这把迷你吉他和雷肖看着它直笑。他就像是，我们能用这东西做什么？所以他就开始弹奏，像这样。然后我办公室里有这个键盘，上面有预录的鼓点和循环。
And so I just started playing the loops and then he would improvise music. And then we just started writing the song. And then we did it too many times. We did it probably like 10 times or something. And I was sick of it by the end. But the first few were great. But then Julian from The Strokes.
所以我开始播放循环乐段，然后他就会即兴演奏音乐。然后我们就开始写这首歌。然后我们唱了太多次了。我们大概唱了10次左右吧。到最后我都听腻了。但前几次很棒。然后来自“笔strokes”乐队的朱利安。
Casablanca. Casablanca. He goes like, dude, I love that song. I want to do a cover of it. And so he did a cover of that song. It's amazing. And it was on the radio. And actually it was on TV.
卡萨布兰卡。卡萨布兰卡。他就像是，老兄，我太喜欢那首歌了。我想翻唱它。所以他翻唱了那首歌。太棒了。它上了电台。实际上它还上了电视。
It was on a commercial. I didn't know that. Really? Yeah. That's great. So you guys were just kind of screwing around and made the song up. And that's how it happened.
它上了一个商业广告。我不知道那件事。真的吗？对。太棒了。所以你们当时就是随便瞎胡闹，然后写出了这首歌。事情就是这样发生的。
I mean, Yeah, but we have no connection to that. So whoever gets money for it, it's not us. Even though you wrote it. Oh, I thought you wrote it. I did. Oh. I just don't know.
我是说，对，但我们跟那没有关系。所以不管是哪个人拿到钱，反正不是我们。尽管是你写的。噢，我以为是你写的。是我写的。噢。我只是不知道。
On SNL, it just gets blurry those years when you write the thing. So you never got paid when they sold it to Toyota. You never saw it die. No. Listen, who's your attorney? I'm going to jot this down. I want to talk to you after the show
在SNL，当你写那些东西的时候，那些年的记忆变得很模糊。所以当他们把它卖给丰田时，你从来没拿过钱。你从来没见它。不。听着，谁是你的律师？我要把这个记下来。节目结束后我想跟你谈谈
because we're going to take these fuckers down. I'm taking down. This is going to be a class act. I don't know. Everybody's getting named in this. We're making friends everywhere. Who's the funniest person to you? Who makes you laugh more than anybody?
因为我们要把这群混蛋搞垮。我要搞垮。这将是一个集体诉讼。我不知道。所有人都得在这个案子里被点名。我们到处在交朋友。对你来说谁是最搞笑的人？谁比任何人都更能让你笑？
I don't like to pick favorites on that stuff. I know. One of them. Will Ferrell. Will Ferrell is always great. I agree. He says yes before we even send him a script. He's like, yeah, I'll do it.
我不想在这种事情上偏心。我懂。其中一个。威尔·法瑞尔。威尔·法瑞尔总是那么棒。我同意。甚至在我们把剧本发给他之前他就说好。他就说，行，我干。
I go, but have you dressed like little Debbie? He's like, I don't care. Let's do it. That's great. And what about your kids come to the Tonight Show and watch Dad work? And are they like, wow, this is amazing or no? No.
我说，但你得打扮得像小黛比那样？他说，我不在乎。干吧。太棒了。那你的孩子们来到《今夜秀》看爸爸工作是什么感觉？他们会觉得，哇，这太惊人了，还是不觉得？不。
They came once when they were babies. I just figured it would be cool for them to see the show. And they wanted to see Timberlake. But that was it. No, they don't come. But they watch every none. That picture of Archie that I have from you sitting at the desk with you sitting next to me,
他们还是婴儿的时候来过一次。我只是觉得让他们看看这个节目会挺酷的。他们想见汀布莱克。但仅此而已。不，他们不来。但他们看每一场。我从你那得到的阿尔奇的那张照片，你坐在办公桌旁，他坐在你旁边，
I just sold this NFT for $36 million. Wow. Just to let you, yeah, yeah. Because I owned it. Nobody gets a piece. Because that's when I sold the Christmas song to Toyota. They said, you get to own all of this. You think you're getting all of my royalties?
我刚刚把这个NFT以3600万美元的价格卖了。哇。跟你说个事，对，对。因为我是它的拥有者。没人能分一杯羹。因为那是我把圣诞歌卖给丰田的时候。他们说，你可以拥有这一切。你以为你能拿到我所有的版税？
That's how NFTs work. Welcome to Ethereum, buddy. And it's all the blockchain. I mean, I know what I'm talking about. You really do. Wait, wait, wait. Do your kids have any sense of what you do? Because you live in that such an adult world
NFT就是这么运作的。欢迎来到以太坊，老兄。这一切都在区块链上。我是说，我知道我在说什么。你确实知道。等等，等等，等等。你的孩子们对你是做什么的有任何概念吗？因为你生活在那个如此成人化的世界里，
that it's late night TV and comedy. Do they have any sense of that at all? Now and then they'll be like, they'll be like, you're Jimmy Fallon or something. Yeah, I go, yeah, yeah. Mr. Fallon to you. I go above your dad. Yeah, Mr. Fallon to you.
那是深夜电视节目和喜剧。他们对此完全没有概念吗？偶尔他们会说，他们会说，你是吉米·法伦或者别的什么。对，我说，对，对。叫我法伦先生。我比，我是你爸爸。对，叫我法伦先生。
But they go, yeah. And then my youngest artist shows, you're famous. I go, yeah, she goes, but not that famous. Who said that? I mean, who taught you that? What kid in school? I want to find the brat in your class that said, I'm not that famous.
但他们会说，对。然后我最小的女儿展示说，你很有名。我说，对，她说，但没那么有名。谁说的？我是说，谁教你的？学校里哪个小屁孩说的，我没那么有名？
Guess what? More famous than her dad. Yes. But honestly, I mean, you are so high profile. You must, every time you guys go out as a family, there must be at least one time when somebody stops you. And so how do you answer that question from your kids when they say, how does that guy know you?
你猜怎么着？比她爸更有名的。是的。但老实说，我是说，你的知名度太高了。你们一家人每次出门，一定至少有一次会被人认出来拦下。那当你的孩子们问起，“那个人怎么认识你”时，你是怎么回答这个问题的？
Yeah, I think they've said it a couple times. I'm like, you know everybody or something. They just think of friends with everybody. You're like, yeah, I work at Minakie. You know what I mean? I got lots of customers. People come in all the time to get their car. Yeah, work at the Jiffy Lou.
对，我想他们问过好几次了。我就说，你认识所有人什么的。他们只是觉得我和所有人都交朋友。你就说，对，我在米纳基上班。你知道我的意思吗？我有好多顾客。人们总是来换车。对，在吉菲鲁滑润油店上班。
Minakie. By the way, I had my, this is a true story. This little girl somewhere in North Carolina, she had a Will Arnett theme birthday party. It was on Twitter and I retweeted and I said, the kids are all right. And she, so this girl, she had this party,
米纳基。顺便说一句，我有过这个，这是一个真实的故事。北卡罗来纳州的某个地方有个小女孩，她办了一个威尔·阿奈特主题的生日派对。这事发在了推特上，我转发了并说，孩子们都挺好的。然后她，所以这个女孩，她办了这个派对，
birthday party. She wore T-shirts with my face on and stuff like that. So first thing, I showed it to my kids. I go, check this out. Last night at dinner. And they both go, oh yeah. Nothing, right? So that was the first thing.
生日派对。她穿着印有我脸的T恤之类的东西。所以第一件事，我把它拿给我的孩子们看。我说，快看这个。昨晚吃晚饭时。他们俩都说，噢， yeah。什么反应都没有，对吧？所以那是第一件事。
Secondly, then when you read the story, and I had a bunch of friends send me, they kept saying, and this little girl had her friends in, and her friends have no idea who Will Arnett is. I mean, they said that at least five times in the article, how nobody knew who that was. And I was like, hey man, why you need to say that? You don't have to write that.
其次，然后当你读到这篇报道时，我有一堆朋友发给我，他们一直说，这个小女孩把她的朋友们请来，她的朋友们根本不知道威尔·阿奈特是谁。我是说，他们在文章里至少说了五遍没有人知道那是谁。然后我就想，嘿，老兄，你为什么非得说这个？你用不着写出来。
You don't need to write that. That the headline is that she did it. She did it. That's it. That's so cool. We don't need to go through how many people knew who I am. I love one of those T-shirts. Yeah.
你用不着写出来。头条新闻应该是她办了这个派对。她办了。就这样。太酷了。我们不需要去数有多少人知道我是谁。我很想要一件那样的T恤。对。
Yeah. I want one of those T-shirts too now. I'm going to get them made. I'm going to get them. I'm going to get this girl on the podcast. We're going to have her on the podcast. She sounds like a smart kid. So weird.
对，我现在也想要一件那样的T恤。我要去定做。我要去弄。我要把这个女孩请到播客上来。我们要请她上播客。她听起来是个聪明的孩子。太诡异了。
I just made my camera blurry. It is true. How did that happen? You got autofocus on that. It's an acting thing. No, it's my face. Oh, that's your face doing that? My face can be blurry if I want to.
我刚才把我的摄像头弄模糊了。这是真的。怎么会这样？你的摄像头有自动对焦功能。这是一种演技。不，那是我的脸。噢，那是你的脸在做那个？如果我想的话，我的脸可以变模糊。
No one has this acting talent. I can make my face look blurry if I want to. And it's tricky for directors. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because you control, because directors ever go stop doing that. Look at me. The fish tank's blurry.
没有人有这种演技。如果我想的话，可以让我的脸看起来很模糊。这对导演来说很难对付。对，对，对。因为你控制着，因为导演会不会说别那样做。看着我。鱼缸是模糊的。
I'm blurry. Everything in this picture, I know you can't see when you're listening to the podcast. You have a camera that has focus on it though? I mean, like, everything's in focus. And look at that. My hand's in focus. So is my face.
我是模糊的。这张照片里的所有东西，我知道你们听播客时看不见。不过你的摄像头有对焦功能对吧？我是说，就像，所有东西都在焦点上。你看那个。我的手在焦点上。我的脸也是。
He's got an auxiliary camera. It's not coming out of the computer. He's got another camera. Oh, there it goes. Oh, now it's fine. There it is. You need a new AC. It's all in the eyes.
他有一个外接摄像头。不是从电脑里出来的。他有另一个摄像头。噢，变清楚了。噢，现在好了。好了。你需要一个新的交流发电机。全在眼睛里。
All in the eye. Uta Hagen. Jimmy, I was thinking about you. Jason and me had dinner. Sorry, Sean. You had already gone back to LA. This summer, at the end of the summer, kind of close to the end of the summer for us,
全在眼里。乌塔·哈根。吉米，我一直在想你。杰森和我一起吃了晚饭。抱歉，肖恩。你已经回洛杉矶了。今年夏天，夏末的时候，差不多快到我们夏天的尾声，
it was our last night on the East Coast. That was fun. It was so much fun. We had so many laughs. And I always feel like every time I see you, we always start laughing. We end up like kind of at the end of the table, just doing bits and screaming.
那是我们在东海岸的最后一个晚上。太好玩了。太有趣了。我们笑了好多次。我总觉得每次见到你，我们都会开始大笑。我们最后总是会在桌子的一端，一直在抖包袱和尖叫。
The three of us were fucking around. And then just like, and then there like 10 other people were like, oh, yeah, yeah, there's the other people. But we just end up fucking around the whole time. So good. I don't even remember who else was there. I know.
我们三个在胡闹。然后就像，旁边还有另外10个人像是在说，噢，对，对，还有其他人在那。但我们自顾自地胡闹了一整晚。太棒了。我甚至不记得当时还有谁在场。我知道。
They're going to love that. No, no, no, that's not you. No, we know who was there. We know who they are. We're not saying, you know. We just ignored them. We just ignored them. That's what you're saying.
他们会爱死这个的。不，不，不，那不是指你。不，我们知道谁在场。我们知道他们是谁。我们没说，你知道的。我们只是忽略了他们。我们只是忽略了他们。这就是你想说的。
Yeah, you were rude. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I was rude because there were some heavy hitters at that dinner. There was a big hit, right? There was some big heavy hitters. And the big topic, the three of us were telling us,
对，你们太粗鲁了。对，对，对。我很粗鲁，因为那场晚宴上有几个重量级人物。是个大场面，对吧？有一些重量级大咖。而主要话题，我们三个在告诉，
get your ass on the podcast. I'm glad this finally happened. I know. Long overdue. Long overdue. But I just, I'm such a fan of all three of you guys. And it couldn't be funnier.
快点上播客吧。我很高兴这最终实现了。我知道。早就该上了。早就该上了。但我只是，我是你们三个人的超级粉丝。而且不能再好笑了。
And when you realize how big this show is, and what it does for people, and you're making so many people laugh. And it's these times when people are going through so much anxiety and all this stuff. Really, you're really helping people. So I really, Not just me saying this,
当你意识到这个节目有多大，它为人们做了什么，你逗笑了那么多人。正是在人们经历如此多的焦虑和所有这些事情的时期。真的，你真的在帮助人们。所以我真的，不仅仅是我这么说，
everyone loves you guys. I mean, and Sean is the best, but. Wait, Jesus. That's a known thing. No, we got to go. Really? You should have just closed the computer right after that. You just slam it.
每个人都爱你们。我是说，肖恩是最好的，不过。等等，天哪。那是众所周知的。不，我们得走了。真的吗？你本该在那之后直接把电脑合上。你直接啪地一声合上。
We could do something, we could do something different and actually talk about Jimmy in front of him, and then he could do the sign-off, our famous sign-off with us. Let's do it. Let's do it. Okay.
我们可以做点别的，我们可以做点与众不同的事，当着吉米的面谈论他，然后他可以和我们一起做结束语，我们著名的结束语。我们来做这个。我们来做这个。好吧。
Jimmy, hang on. So this is going to be awkward. So guys, how great was that having Jimmy on the show? So great. I love him. I can't believe the trajectory of success that he's had from when he was 23 years old. I can't believe he started when he was 23.
吉米，等一下。所以这会很尴尬。那么伙计们，让吉米上节目感觉多棒？太棒了。我爱死他了。我不敢相信他从23岁起取得的成功轨迹。我不敢相信他23岁就开始干这个了。
I know. And I've been wanting to have him on for a while. We couldn't make his deal. We couldn't make his dates. He's a very busy guy. He does the show. So we've been, this has been a long time coming.
我知道。我一直想请他来。我们敲不定他的合约。我们敲不定他的档期。他是个大忙人。他要做节目。所以我们一直在，这可以说是蓄谋已久了。
And it's one of those ones. I knew that you were going to maybe do the show. I knew he was going to do it. Maybe even when we saw him, then it was a possibility. So I was just excited that he was on the show today. Yeah. Every time,
而且这就是那种情况。我知道你可能会上这个节目。我知道他会来的。甚至可能在我们见到他时，那就已经有可能了。所以我只是很高兴他今天能来节目。对。每次，
I feel like every time I see him, he always makes me laugh. Never, ever doesn't make me laugh. Here's the other thing I'll say about him. He's like the, Sean, and you'll attest to this. Such a talented guy in the real old school, a sense of the word.
我觉得每次我见到他，他总是能让我笑。从来、从来没有不让我笑的时候。关于他，我还要说另一件事。他就像是，肖恩，你也能作证。在最老派的意义上，这是一个非常有才华的人。
Yeah. Really funny, very musical. Yes. Good actor. Yeah. Not a lot of the people can do, there's like three people in the world that can do what he does.
对。真的很搞笑，非常有音乐才华。是的。好演员。对。没多少人能做到，世界上大概只有三个人能做到他所做的事。
Yeah. Like look at Jason. Jason has half of those, like half of one of those things. Jason hasn't said anything. No. Jason, what do you like about Jimmy? Talk about,
对。就像看看杰森。杰森只有那些的一半，就像其中一样东西的一半。杰森什么都没说。不。杰森，你喜欢吉米什么？说说，
I like that he can sing and he can dance and he can laugh and he can cry. Yeah. He's got a great wife and a great life. And he's nice to people. He takes pictures with the public. And you know what? He pretty much ends his,
我喜欢他能唱歌，能跳舞，能笑，还能哭。对。他有一个好妻子，生活也很美满。他对人很好。他会和公众合影。你知道吗？他几乎以同样的方式结束他的，
his show the same way we end it. By saying, By saying, By saying, See, see, see, Jimmy, at this, at this moment, usually on the, I know it's by or something.
他的节目结束的方式和我们的一样。通过说，通过说，通过说，听着，吉米，在这个，在这个时刻，通常在，我知道是再见什么的。
Yeah. We all try to think up somehow to wiggle in the word by into. Yeah, I got, But I've been giving Sean shit because he's been trying to land it so, so much early. Sean's just trying to get out of it
对。我们都绞尽脑汁想怎么把“再见”这个词塞进。对，我有，但我一直在拿肖恩开涮，因为他太早、太急着把这句话说出口了。肖恩只是想脱身
so much earlier in an inorganic way. Well, no, no, this, Jason, by the way, this is very awkward for me to hear the posts in interview talk. Yeah. But Jason really nailed it more than you guys.
早得多，而且用一种很不自然的方式。好吧，不，不，这，杰森，顺便说一句，听他们在访谈结束后这么聊天对我很尴尬。对。但杰森确实比你们抓得更准。
Thank you. Well, I just, I sit on the sidelines. He said, I have a great wife. I have a great life. Right. I laugh.
谢谢。好吧，我只是，我作壁上观。他说，我有一个好妻子。我有一个好生活。对。我爱笑。
And I also cry. And I also. Bye. Oh. Bye. Bye. Oh my gosh. We're going to punch that up.
而且我也会哭。而且我也。再见。噢。再见。再见。噢天哪。我们要把它弄得更有爆点。
We're going to punch it up. Can you? Yeah. No, we're going to punch it up. We're going to punch that up. You want me to do it one more time? Sure. Hold the bye.
我们要把它弄得更有爆点。能吗？对。不，我们要把它弄得更有爆点。我们要把它弄得更有爆点。你想让我再来一次吗？当然。稳住这个“再见”。
You got to do the bye. Bye. Would you also buy Coastal, maybe? We use that one. We have used that one. And I will say, just because we're still rolling. Yeah.
你得说“再见”。再见。你会不会也买海岸，也许？我们用过那个。我们用过那个。而且我要说，就因为我们还在录音。对。
You know, Jason always makes it like personal, but in this way, he's always talking about Ryan Reynolds. He was like, you're a little angel who came into your life. Stop talking about other dude's wives. Yeah. She's a great lady.
你知道，杰森总是把它搞得很个人化，但在这种情况下，他总是在谈论瑞安·雷诺兹。他就像是，你是那个走进你生命中的小天使。别再谈论别人的老婆了。对。她是个好太太。
Shut the fuck up. It's really creepy. Such a great wife. I'm going to, I'm going to punch you in a half an hour when I see you. It was a good call. You know, it was, what did he call it?
他妈的闭嘴吧。真的很诡异。真是个好妻子。我一会见到你就要给你一拳。这是一个好电话。你知道的，这叫什么来着？
He does have a great, you do happen to have a great wife. I've all three of you that Jason really nailed it because I have a great wife, a great life. I do like to laugh and I sometimes cry and I always
他确实有一个好，你碰巧确实有一个好妻子。你们三个里杰森真的抓得最准，因为我有一个好妻子，一个好生活。我确实喜欢笑，我有时会哭，而且我总是
bye. Bye. See you dudes. Love you guys. Love you too. That's a first. That's great. Thanks, Jimmy.
再见。再见。回头见，伙计们。爱你们，伙计们。我也爱你们。头一遭。太棒了。谢谢，吉米。
Thank you, buddy. You're the greatest. Love you, buddy. Say hi to that nice wife of yours. Say hi to your wife. Say hi to your wife. Same. Back to you guys.
谢谢你，老兄。你是最棒的。爱你的，老兄。替我向你那位好妻子问好。替你妻子问好。替你妻子问好。我也是。交回给你们。
Be well. Thank you. Bye, buddy. This is the after credits wrap up that he doesn't even know about. Because it's all, we have to have our own wrap up too. You know,
保重。谢谢。再见，老兄。这是他甚至都不知道的演职员表后的收尾。因为这一切，我们必须也有我们自己的收尾。你知道，
I have an, I have an admission. The other, the other night of trying to fall asleep and trying to, you know, you try to think of things when you're falling asleep. I started thinking about different buys.
我有一个，我有一个坦白。前几天晚上尝试入睡时，尝试，你知道，当你快睡着时你会想一些事情。我开始思考不同的“再见”。
And I think about what, what things Ryan would buy, you know. And I came up with five or six things, but I didn't have a pad of paper next to me and I've forgotten them all now. So, What was the gummy load? What was the gummy load?
我在想瑞安会买什么东西，你知道的。我想出了五六个，但我旁边没有记事本，现在全忘光了。所以，那个软糖剂量是多少？那个软糖剂量是多少？
The gummy load was about 50 or 60 grams, bro. What the fuck? Are you an animal? I don't know. I don't do that stuff. Well, come on. Wow. Yeah.
那个软糖剂量大约是50到60克，兄弟。他妈的什么？你是个动物吗？我不知道。我不搞那些东西。得了吧。哇。
So, so that Jimmy Fallon, he's not fantastic. He's great. He's just a pillar. Always great. Just a real, a real treasure.
所以，那个吉米·法伦，他难道不棒吗？他太棒了。他简直是个顶梁柱。总是那么棒。简直是一笔真正的财富。
Will, thank you for bringing him to, to our show. That was so much fun. He's so great. And also, can I just say, I just want to let everybody know that,
威尔，谢谢你把他带到，带到我们的节目里。太有趣了。他太棒了。另外，我能说吗，我只想让每个人都知道，
that Jimmy's new show, that's my jam is going to air January 3rd, 2022 in its regular time slot, 9pm on Mondays. Yeah. There's a lot of good laughs today. Thank you for that. A lot of good ones.
吉米的新节目《那是我的强项》将于2022年1月3日在其常规黄金时段周一晚上9点播出。对。今天有很多精彩的笑料。谢谢你们带给我们的欢乐。有很多精彩的时刻。
I can hear you guys thinking. No, I'm not. We got it. We're going to cut in the other one. We're going to cut in the other one. We are. No, no, but he, but it wasn't as good.
我能听到你们在想什么。不，我没有。我们录好了。我们要剪进另一个里。我们要剪进另一个里。我们会的。不，不，但那个，但没那么好。
Because he said, I laugh, I cry, and I always buy. What? You got to have, the buys got to have, to do with something. This is,
因为他说，我笑，我哭，而且我总是买。什么？你得让这个“买”字，跟某些事情扯上关系。这，
thinking about this stuff is going to make me sick. I can almost taste the, BIO! Beautiful. Smart. Smart. Smart.
想这些东西快把我弄吐了。我几乎能尝到，生物！太美了。聪明。聪明。
Insane. Smart Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太疯狂了。聪明。我们的下一期节目将在下周发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客或 Wondry App 上的 Wondry Plus 提前且无广告收听。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。